[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef with a
true Louisiana legacy Isaac toups was
born in Cajun country to a food-loving
family that's lived in Louisiana for
more than 300 years and from bbq's and
fish fries to shrimp and crawfish boils
his early years were filled with flavor
after starting out as a professional
chef he worked for Emeril Lagasse in New
Orleans and that's where he and his wife
Amanda opened their own venue soups
meatery
featuring house cured meats and other
dishes sure to please any Cajun carnival
two years ago they added to south
located inside the southern food and
beverage museum some of those recipes
are featured in his new cookbook chasing
the Gator chef Isaac toups you have put
me in my happy place with welcome let's
and let's start with the place where the
knife is it's a very dramatic beginning
it's one of my favorite dishes that the
new restaurant tube south and I always
want to put this dish on however it my
other restaurant had a different pork
chop dish which I'd have a riot when we
change it the big double cuts go to
right this one yeah our world was one of
the giant plate of fried pork chops to
make the fried pork chop sandwich was
the quintessential New Orleans dish
fried in bone-in pork chop sandwich I
put my own spin on it with my father's
pickles and espresso aioli and lettuce
and you see you can just bite into it oh
these are these are my lacquered collard
greens plenty of pork we have our
cornbread dirty rice essential that's my
grandmother's dish and we have our steam
syrup and pies which are just absolutely
dynamite fact my all my parents you know
aunts knuckles they fight over them this
is one of our signature cocktails enjoy
it's never too early to drink in New
Orleans now you know I have to say full
disclosure I do know the difference
between Cajun and Creole country but I
have to tell you can date your family
back to the 1700s right but you you say
that it's not just a lifestyle it's a
mindset to be Cajun absolutely it's it's
kind of a it's a terroir it's a flavor
it's this whole mindset it's using stuff
from the land it's really we kept our
culture
one of the few places in in the south
that really just really embraced that
culture and really liked to bring those
influences from France and brothers
influenced stuff from Nova Scotia as
well we melded with the Creoles we have
Mexico right next to us and even
nowadays we have a wonderful Vietnamese
community we have the Irish we have the
Italian Native American Native American
we have a wonderful melting pot that is
New Orleans and coming from Cajun
country this melting pot just works in
Cajun food I love that you said that
your family was a family of foodies even
before foodies was the term that
everybody was using you had these
influences even your dad was bringing to
you right man my dad's a dentist so the
rest of my family and but my dad was
always the one who's like oh let's go
try this new thing let's go try the the
kimchi yeah in the Vietnamese market way
back in the day is like oh here have
some stinky cabbage and as a kid like no
you're gonna try it
walking into Emeralds Emeril Lagasse's
Delmonico restaurant at the age of 20
with eight months of food experience if
that much if that much I walk in green
as hell didn't know what I was doing
walking walking to there got a job just
on a whim and worked myself up for there
for ten years that was like the finest
emerald restaurant in the town right
that was bold totally no it was dumb
yeah it was there's a different side of
bold it's just like I'll just walk into
this restaurant and then got a job and
there's the fried cook was a fry cook
and work myself up to second command
before I started break off and did my
own fishmonger you do a boulder dumb on
that yeah I was a fishmonger for three
months right when I took my culinary
breaks I got a little burn and I'm like
I don't want to be a chef anymore wit
soul fish and realize that I do not deal
well with customers and almost slap
someone with a fish open up my own
restaurant right what was that like to
go out on your own with your wife Amanda
scary and another silly part a company
model is we're too too dumb to be scared
which is a really good because like to
have money right it's very very scary
open up your own restaurant but as total
rookies were like let's just go do it
and no slapping the customers let's just
do it I've only had to throw one
customer out
dude who's way too inebriated who need
to be shown the sidewalk book it's sort
of this love letter to the way you grew
up yeah and to that Cajun influence what
was it like for somebody who doesn't
like to measure and do recipes in the
traditional sense to do a book like this
um hellacious so we had to go back and
like measure everything that was already
in my head which is difficult so what we
had to do was like take a pinch of salt
Isaac what's your pinch of salt I
reached him with my forefinger entire
teaspoon I'm like oh oh but my pinch is
a teaspoon that was the hardest part
going back and like trying to like get
in my brain and get out you have stories
upon stories but as you sign this dish
it tell us if there's any one past or
present you could share this meal with
who would it be oh you know what I think
it's the Marquis de Sade because if
something someone's gonna throw a party
that I want to cater it's that guy thank
you for more on chef and the dish gosh
head to our website at CBS this morning